hello and welcome to this video against
pacheco free hand he has to suffer
because I just lost again against some
some damn cheater I'm pretty sure it was
a cheat about you it cannot be totally
shined I kind of I didn't know I stopped
the video somewhere and i simply i know
the whole town looked fishy the game
looked for sheep I don't know let's see
what I can do against PT Capri this is I
am the key lyricist the name right
killdeer is right so what now Bishop to
f3 he promised he will probably go some
g5 stuff hmm interesting ok I will I
need some counter place on and go with C
6 the question is where now you know
going back and maybe go back but i would
like to play more actively so i go here
if he takes it this costs quite some
time it might still be good for them but
i'm not a huge fan of playing back to
the aid or something like that
I can take it but I have 93 and so on an
interesting idea for white is to take
the night and then take age five
I've got to Bishop then but the worst
pawn structure ever okay he goes for
that Jack that I don't really think it's
that brilliant if I take them Queenie
too i guess but i have a couple of
options queen-to-be six blunders the
Queen unfortunately otherwise it would
be would be a good move hmm i can go
night at four well just stay then let's
let's think about this for a moment
Queenie to have neither for anyway so
maybe this one lending some possible
support after this yeah no I could back
so if he takes it would open up the long
diagonal okay if I go a three here or
queen a five not sure Queen 85 I guess
it for Queen to b4 this is a king's
indian after all you have to play as
actively as possible
things in is really an opening that
forces you to be active if you play
passive moves and hang around you you
usually I just verse doing the correct
active moves though is a is a difficult
thing so I'm not saying that I'm doing a
good job here just try let's see
gee how does it defensive or I don't
know how not sure if it is such a big
deal if I get to take it but ok so here
I can't take c4 I can take I think I'll
take here right it's nothing wrong with
that I might have Bishop a six now or
Bishop e61 problem is if he takes on f4
and the diagonal opens up there's always
a 3 i'm getting at the c3 night
they're against some accounts it's
difficult to play with when you have
this cheating suspicion right away and I
had a long string of cheetahs from the
UAE from Kuwait from Dubai or whatever
yeah all those the rain all those Gulf
states i really don't know why I've no
idea it happened a lot there were lots
of cheating incidents that never got to
be on the video and those countries
there really a feature allot them so
whenever I get Wow an opponent from one
of those countries again I'm kind of sub
suspicious so I want this by the way
okay I'll do this come on this looks
like it would reply let's not waste time
taking the rook and the pawn this looks
okay right this should be good for black
anything better no never porn up right
or not yes I'm upon up so Bishop a6 no
it's still kind of kind of annoying here
this this stuff i'd like to go ahead
fire i think i'll take and play a 5m
getting the super big center a chick
with the rook 194 is kind of annoying
Bishop takes then yeah look G 1 this is
not great yeah coming night she won a 95
is annoying let's see if I cannot take
be to hear and they have bashai at five
as well I hope I'm not overlooking some
kind of a becky checkmater would be
hugely embarrassing so um what now he
wants to go 95 there any way to prevent
this completely probably not check here
yeah but close its close to that I can
almost prevent it completely I mean here
you can actually move the rook it's not
it's not a mate so check check and look
up to I was thinking don't see a maid
and threatening we should be to check
which is kind of nice white resides poor
tough game yeah I'm not sure about the
opening at all but it was a typical
complicated Kings Indian fight yes so a
five this one yeah that age five is of
course this is a very debatable decision
that didn't want to play passively and
here if he allows night at four I'm in
good shape so he is forced to take it i
think the critical continuation is what
the computer is giving taking the second
night and take him this is probably good
for what I mean my pawn structure is a
mess and I'm a porn down and it's not
clear what i'm doing i can go here but
let's say he cancels long now it's
somewhat messy but it's good for wider
this is probably a key moment of the
game i think here i have a decent
position went back to you too running
into this and now he decided to keep it
on the board yeah i don't know a couple
of options I can take the five now all
this I think this is also possible way
92 queen bee form an interesting option
for white is to play age five and
something along these lines this is very
funky with it with the bishop on h8 and
computer gives white half upon which is
very hard to to get to interpret what
what this actually means the line runs
like this takes takes Bishop takes pawn
takes Andrew cage for and justice the
line that
and now it's going down to 0.3 wow we
had super complicated ending its equal
material but completely yeah as
non-symmetrical as you can get tough to
say then the game it took an oblique 95
this is just doesn't work here because
of night xt5 this is this yeah I'm not
sure ever played in the best possible
way with the engine is always giving
that two or three pawns so Jan you know
I think it's okay the engine didn't
didn't show any young any a spike in
whites favor so I probably have played
it reasonably well and it says it's a
very very tough kind of game in the
Kings Indian if Y place that ambitiously
was g4 and age for this is a lot like I
play it and I know that these positions
are super double-edged okay well thanks
for watching